you can expect more arrests of illegal
immigrants at federal state and local
courthouses immigration authorities are
making official a policy that has drawn
widespread criticism from pro
immigration advocates national
correspondent William la jeunesse looks
at both sides tonight from Los Angeles
for every criminal public safety threat
that we can't take custody of in the
safety and security of the county jail
means one of our officers has to knock
on the door
that's why Immigration and Customs
Enforcement is doubling down on a policy
allowing agents to arrest criminal
aliens at the courthouse this policy -
when they can arrest people in
courthouses makes sense in the past ice
arrested criminal aliens in jail it was
seamless safe inefficient until
sanctuary cities banned the practice
immigrants supporters want the courts
off-limits fearing otherwise innocent
relatives could also be deported that
are oppressive and endanger families of
our citizens but the new ice directive
says agents have no intention of
sweeping traffic or city courts for
nonviolent offenders if you look at the
policy it's pretty specific that the the
arrests at the courthouses is to go
after targets criminal aliens who are
targets not victims not witnesses not
family members another concern a recent
increase in unaccompanied minors
crossing the border Holmen blames a
recent 9th Circuit Court ruling that
prohibits DHS from holding children for
months or even longer until their Asylum
hearing the president wants a policy to
change that it finally ends the horrible
and dangerous practice of catch and
release the Ninth Circuit ruled
unaccompanied children are entitled to a
bond hearing and must be placed in the
least restrictive environment available
usually with a parent or relative and
many never show up in court
critics say catch and release policies
incentivize more illegal immigration
right William thank you